what happened in the past five six years
is that all the wars and changes in the
Middle East actually strengthened Iran's
position
Iran has sort of emerged if you would as
a great power in the region now there
are many people who say that's not
really true this is nothing that Iran
did that gave it this status it actually
is a weak country it has a weak economy
it has a divided society all of that
might be true but it takes ten minutes
being in the Middle East to know that
the Iranians think they're a great power
and the Arabs
around them think they're a great power
and a lot of politics is about
perception the perception in the region
is that the glass is half-full for Iran
is half-empty for the Arab world the
compared to 2001 or 2002 Iran's
influence in the region has expanded and
the influence that the Arab world has
declined that Iran militarily feels it
has much more elbow room if the US
wasn't there the Arab countries now feel
vulnerable that Iran has effectively
penetrated the Arab world
it controls southern Iraq it wields a
lot of influence in Iraq Iran is big
player now in Lebanon much more so than
before 2006 and look the Palestinians
are not completely divided into two
territories and guess what the Arab
governments are only influential in one
territory and the Iranians are more
influential in the other one Iran has a
lot more influence than it had in the
past there's much more capability it had
in the past the other issues are really
a reaction or a reflection of this knows
the sectarian issue is becoming more
important because it falls right in the
middle of an Iranian era rivalry the
language of the Arabs in the region is
anti Iran anti-shia
yeah and so long as the Iranians and the
Arabs are in this rivalry Iranians are
she as most of the Arabs are Sunni
sectarianism is an issue so is Iran in
Arab relations is an issue
nationalism becomes very important the
other issues even the Palestinian issue
is become now a political football
between Arabs and Iranians I mean
people argue that the whole purpose for
an Annapolis conference and a new peace
effort was to create a united arab front
against Iran so Iran was really the
ulterior motive to bigger the bigger
fish in the picture now for everybody in
the region Iran poses a challenge for
the Arab countries this is classical
balance of power issue it's not
necessarily just about the Iranian
regime it's a country of 70 million
people very wealthy very large very
nationalistic with imperial ambitions
going back to the Shahs period it's now
feels that it's been let loose in the
Persian Gulf and any country whether
it's Egypt Saudi Arabia UAE any country
reacts to a relative loss of power with
anxiety so everybody looks and says can
we go back to rebalancing Iran that's a
natural reaction the United States has a
challenge because the United States for
a very long time invested in a vision of
the Middle East which was based on the
idea that the Arab world is the most
dominant factor and stability in the
Middle East depends on stability in the
Arab world now all of a sudden we see
that Iran is a lot more important from
Lebanon to Palestine issue two
particularly the Persian Gulf where
everything we care about right now is
over there and to Iraq which is our most
important you know issue in the region
now all of a sudden the Arab world that
we invested so much in is not able to
control and influence and shape things
to the extent that was the case five
years ago we have to play catch-up with
reality now one of the ways in which the
Bush administration is trying to do this
is to take the clock back to 2002 that's
not going to happen easily bloodlessly
effortlessly Iran's not going to go back
in its cage easily the question is can
we cobble together a new framework for
the region that deals with the reality
which is Iran is more influential Arabs
maybe a little less come to a new
for Israel the problem is very different
Israel and Iran now essentially are the
two great powers in this region the Arab
world is sandwiched between you you had
it for a period but a unipolar situation
in the Middle East where Israel was
conventional military dominant the Arab
world by and large was becoming an ally
of the u.s. Syria or Libya were not
mattering much Iraq was broken down by
the u.s. Iran all of a sudden is emerged
as the counterweight to Israel he's
trying to shore up the Arab Street
against Israel very Yulin rhetoric
against Israel anti Holocaust rhetoric
pro-palestinian rhetoric rejecting
talking etc and it's trying to woo the
Arab world away from Israel and Israel
in the United States are trying to woo
the Arab world against Iran but that
means that the real power players are
not the Arab or the Arab world is the
prize in a bigger fight between Israel
and Iran over power in this region now
Israel
whenever you have nuclear capability
there's always a fear about its use but
I don't think that's the really most
important issue here I mean look at
South Asia Pakistan and India hate one
another they have a live issue between
them called Kashmir ever since they've
gone nuclear
they haven't gone to war one another
there is a nuclear peace in southeast
South Asia now but but but the reality
is that the issue is a bit more complex
it's not that whether Iran the minute it
gets the bomb is going to launch it
first of all Iran is many years away
from a bomb and many were years away
from getting parity with Israel which
has some 200 nuclear weapons and second
strike capability the reality is that
when India and Pakistan each one nuclear
they weren't different parts India
relaxed began to focus on economic
growth and real things Pakistan became
much more dangerous became much more
adventurous take it would send jihadi
fighters into Kashmir and Afghanistan
and even right now the Pakistanis do
things that other countries
not get away with against the United
States was giving him money why because
they believed that they have some kind
of immunity because of the nuclear
capability India will not invade
Pakistan even though it has a bigger
army now the question is which one will
Iran be will Iran be India or will Iran
be Pakistan and then the bigger question
is an Iranian bomb will play the same
role that American nuclear weapons
played in Europe during the Cold War the
Soviets had many more tanks many more
soldiers they could have just walked
into Western Europe we couldn't match
their numbers but once you have the
nuclear weapons in the picture
conventional superiority becomes
irrelevant the new nuclear weapons are
an equalizer for in the minds of Middle
Eastern countries Israel has absolute
conventional superiority it is a
fantastic military which has proven
itself in war it's highly
technologically advanced and it has a
superb Air Force now the minute you have
a nuclear capability all of that
conventional superiority will become
irrelevant
so for Israel a nuclear Iran is an
absolute strategic loss I'm not
convinced that there will be nuclear war
I mean one never knows but I do not
convinced that that's the the most
likely scenario the most likely outcome
but you one can be absolutely sure and
once Iran has a nuclear weapon Israel
will lose its conventional superiority
and the balance of power in the region
will shift Israel will not be able to
for instance operate in Syria or in
south Lebanon with the ease that it does
many Arab countries that right now
complain about Iranian nuclear weapons
may actually benefit from a nuclear
shield and become a lot more ant is
really and and if you you'll end up with
a much more with a much more constricted
Israel in a in a Middle East which still
has many life unresolved issues that
threat
his real super